Hello, internets, and welcome
to this week's episode of
Google+ Developers Live.
So we're going to take a break
from the best practices
episodes that we've been doing,
and we're going to be
showing you the Quickstarts.
So this week, we'll be doing the
C# Quickstart on Windows,
and the short version of what
this does is it's going to
create a web server built on top
of ASP.NET, and it's going
to host a [INAUDIBLE]
that will render the Sign-In
button, sign in the user, and
then pass authorization tokens
to the server in order to make
API calls server side.
So if you want to get started
with this, the launching off
point is going to be
developers.googl
e.com/plus/quickstart/C#.
So let's take a look
at my screen and
walk through the sample.
So here you have the landing
page for the C# sample, and
inside of this set of
instructions is going to be--
the first command is going to
be for cloning the actual
sources from our GitHub
project page
into your local machine.
So what you would do is just
copy this command, get clone,
GitHub.com/Googl
e+/G+quickstartC#.get.
So let's run that command.
So what it's doing is it's just
copying the sources from
GitHub into my local machine.
So now, in the folder that I've
set up for my Git Bash, I
will now have the Google+
Quickstart.
So here's the Quickstart
itself.
Now what I will do is, I'm
just going to open up the
solution inside of
Visual Studio.
So once the solution's opened,
what I'm going to have to do
is set up the client credentials
before I'm going
to be able to make API calls
on behalf of the user.
So what I'm going to have to do
next then is set up an API
project inside of the
API's console.
The place that you
start here is
code.google.com/APIs/console.
Here we have the
API's console.
For those of you who are
unfamiliar with it, this is
where you create all the
projects that use Google APIs.
So if I want to create a project
that uses the Google+
APIs, for example, then this
is where I would start.
So let's create a new project.
When you create the project, the
first thing you need to do
is come up with a name
for your project.
So the name that you give your
project is just for you.
This is not going to be a
public-- this is not going to
be public facing information.
This is just information so
that you know one of your
projects from another.
I'll just create a project
for this GDL.
Here's the project
that's created.
And after the project gets
created, you then turn on the
services that your project
is going to consume.
So because this project is only
going to be using the
Google+ API, I just need to
turn on the Google+ API.
So it's right in the middle, and
it's sorted alphabetically
for those of you who are hunting
through, and the plus
in Google+ actually appears
as a P in the
alphabetical ordering.
After you've created your
project, and you've turned on
the service for Google+, you now
are ready to create your
authorization credentials.
So what I did there was I
clicked this Create An OAuth2
client ID button, the
big blue one.
And inside of here is going to
be the branding information
that will be facing
your customers.
So when you label this
information, please take the
time to ensure that the
information is accurate and is
consistent with the branding for
your particular product.
Because this is just a GDL
Quickstart, I'm just going to
have a less meaningful name,
but this is fine for now.
So I'm going to be creating a
web application, and I'm going
to be running it from local host
port 4567, just as is set
up inside of the tutorial.
The reason that I switched this
also was because HTTP
versus HTTPS matters.
So when you set up these
projects, pay extra careful
attention to the port and the
protocol that you're using,
because it needs to match
wherever you're going to be
running this code.
So I'll create that client ID,
and after that's done, what
will happen is there'll be a
client ID and a client secret.
And so these are the credentials
that Google uses
to ensure that the people who
are accessing the APIs are the
right ones for that particular
project.
So make sure that you protect
this information on your
deployed applications.
Here we have the
project again.
I'm going to open signin.ashx,
and this will actually open
the code-behind.
And so inside of the code-behind
is the settings,
your client ID and your
client secret.
So these are the ones that you
got from the API console.
So here's the client ID, the
client secret, and now, if we
run the sample, you will see
the application running.
Here's the sign-in dialogue.
I click it.
I'm presented then with this
request for permission.
So all of the services that are
set up and included inside
of the scopes will appear
here for your users.
So make sure that when you
request scopes, you request
the right ones for what your
users will be doing.
After you've done this, you
accept, because you trust this
product, and then after you
accept, the sample will run.
So what happens when the sample
runs is, up top we
render some really minimal UI,
and then we use the JavaScript
client library in order to
retrieve a user profile, and
then we perform a RESTful API
call to the server endpoint
which was created.
And then that will retrieve HTML
for the people that are
visible to this app.
So there's a server side call
that's happening there.
There's a client call that's
happening there.
And so once you've got this
working, then you've seen the
Google+ Client Libraries running
inside of your Google+
application.
And that's pretty much all
there is to it for the
Quickstart.
Now, let's take a closer look at
some of the things that are
happening behind the scenes
when this is done.
I'm going to put a breakpoint
in here, and this breakpoint
will cause the code to pause
when we have retrieved the
user's list of circled people.
So let's see where the
endpoint is for that.
So here's the request path that
contains people, and here
you can see something that
starts to look like
a Google API call.
So you have this PeopleFeed
object, you've got- PS is
actually a plus service object,
and then inside of the
plus service object, all
of the client APIs are
encapsulated into methods
and objects.
So this is a real
simple API call.
Doing this does not require
very much setup, very much
work, and when you run it, the
result that you get is going
to be that object representing
the list of people.
I'll just go back to
my server again.
We'll run the sample again, and
here's where that server
has set up that PeopleFeed
request.
And after it's concluded with
that fetch command, you'll
have, inside of this PeopleFeed,
an object that
just represents something from
that users Google account.
This gives you a general idea
of how to get started with
Google+ and the Google+ Client
Libraries and C#.
And feel free to ask questions
on our Google+ Developers page
in the Google+ Developer
community on Google+.
And feel free to reach out to
us directly on Google+ if
you'd like to as well.
Once you have all this set up,
you're pretty much ready for
C# development, but what if you
wanted to use or create a
client application.
So this is sort of one of the
problems that our client
libraries team has been thinking
of, and they recently
announced a new version of
the Google API libraries.
And this is built on top of the
PCL, and so when you use
the new library, you can put
your applications on Windows
Phone, on Windows desktop,
and in the new Windows 8.
Feel free to check out that new
library, but there are few
quirks to it that I want
to share with you
before we move on.
So I'll close the solution, and
I'll open up-- so I have
another one.
I have another solution that
has been updated to the new
client library.
When you set up these projects,
it's basically the
same setup that we
had. before.
You just want to add references
for DotNetOpenAuth,
the Google APIs library, OAuth2,
and then the Google
Apis.Plus.v1.
So if you look inside of my
project references, you can
see where I've added
these four.
The next thing you need to do is
you need to turn on the New
Git packages for all the BCL
stuff and also for the
dependencies of the new
client library.
So the major dependency is
the Microsoft HTTP client
libraries, and so you want to
make sure that you include
that, and then that should
also pull in the other
components.
You also will need to pull in
the [INAUDIBLE] for .NET
framework library and then
the Newtonsoft.JSON.
We used to ship the sample with
Newtonsoft.JSON in it,
but now that you can acquire
these libraries very easily,
get the latest ones using New
Git, it just makes sense to
instead ship it without, and
then have people who are
playing with the API to just
add it themselves.
So that's pretty much it.
Everything looks and works
exactly the same.
When I updated to this new
client library inside of my
test app, there were absolutely
no changes that I
had to make to my code.
Everything just was using
the same API footprint.
So there were no major breaking
changes except you
just now have to be able to
import all these libraries
that are required for
Microsoft HTTP.
So that's it for today.
Thank you for watching, and
come back next week at the
same time, 2:30 PM PST, to
watch another episode of
Google+ Developers Live.